Remember when we saw those really cool images
of Pluto?
How did a dwarf planet send those us all the
way from space?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews.
The first spy satellites had actual film cameras
onboard, with canisters equipped with parachutes
to get the photos back to the ground, but
as we advanced, satellites began using digital
cameras, on-board computers and radio waves
to send data long distances.
Today, the MSL Curiosity rover is on Mars,
Juno is almost to Jupiter and Cassini is visiting
Saturn…
All of these missions are constantly sending
data to scientists back on Earth, but how?
It’s all thanks to the Deep Space Network.
It became clear really early on in the space
program, that scientists needed a way to constantly
be able to communicate with their satellites.
Unfortunately for them, the Earth rotates,
and as it does, satellites appear and disappear
So, 50 years ago, NASA’s JPL began the Deep
Space Network.
Three sites were selected to receive data
from Space, one in California, one in Spain
and another in Australia -- 120 degrees apart
so together they could see the whole sky 24
hours a day.
On each site an array of massive satellite
dishes ranging from 24 to 70 meters in diameter
were constructed.
This is the most powerful and sensitive communication
system in the world.
The 70-meter antenna is able to hear quote
"a whisper from a billion kilometers" away.
Now, because of launch weight restrictions
and power limits, broadcast equipment on spacecrafts
has to be light, so engineers are forced to
use relatively low-powered transmitters -- like,
20 watts (that’s way less than the average
incandescent light bulb).
And it gets weaker as it travels through space.
By the time the signal reaches the dish, it
can be "20-billion times less than the power
needed to power a digital watch."
When a signal wave hits the dish, it's reflected
to a highly sensitive receiver at the center
-- and put through a crazy powerful amplifier.
The amplifiers are cooled to near absolute
zero, to minimize electrical interference
from the equipment itself.
So, because of their position on the globe,
no matter where the satellites are, at least
one DSN dish will be able to hear the broadcast.
Signals from near-Earth missions are strong,
and can be picked up relatively easily.
For deep-space missions, it’s a bit harder.
To strengthen the signal, probes in space
use both low and high-gain antennas.
Low-gain antennas are like ones used at local
radio stations -- they spread their power
in every direction at once.
The tiny microwaves of a high-gain antenna
are focused, like a laser, so the signal strength
is stronger when it reaches Earth.
If the spacecraft points it's high-gain antenna
at Earth, the DSN can pick it up.
The Earth-based antennas also have to move
here on the ground.
High-gain antennas are extremely directional,
because you don't want to lose at data stream!
So, the ability to point directly at what
we’re trying to communicate with is super
important.
But even if the spacecraft is not pointed
at Earth, the DSN can still “see” the
low gain signal.
According to NASA, this is what makes low-gain
antennas useful for things like emergencies.
This Earth-sized marvel of engineering is
not only practical for space exploration,
but necessary!
Without each of these three sites, there would
be a time when spacecraft would be on their
own, in the dark, in the vastness of space.
The Deep Space Network lets them phone home
whenever they need to.
And you can see this communication happening
right now!